lakers lebron james gets pacers fan
ejected and returned from suspension
which uh
you know what a sweetheart of a guy
lebron is this is a new york post story
lebron james just can't stop getting
ejected from games this time two fans in
his first game back from his one game
suspension for bloody and pistons
forward isaiah stewart lebron had a
couple of pacers fan ejected from los
angeles win wednesday night in
indianapolis uh lebron brought the
referees over to two fans sitting
quartzite again bridge field house and
angrily pointed at them yelling this one
right effin here the fan a young man and
a woman were then asked to leave with
two minutes and 29 seconds left and over
time when upsing gestures and language
come in
come into it it cannot be tolerated
there's a difference from cheering for
your team and not wanting the other team
to win and things i would never say to a
fan and they shouldn't say to me so this
is lebron saying that adam i'm going to
go to you first since you're a die hard
lebron fan i'm not a die-hard lebron fan
i do respect
greatness i mean heavy is the head that
wears the crown no disputing there okay
so you know
best player of all time top two okay i
got jordan and lebron i got him then
maybe you got kareem in there
that's me
but
in my opinion i don't even know a story
with sabonis i mean you would have him
in your tongue
greatest passing big man of all time
thank you for that jersey but here's the
deal how many lebron gets hated on
like how much [ __ ] do you think has
talked to lebron from the stands
every single game yeah
the fact that he ran up on these two
people courtside yeah pointed them out
and full on these two these two
how bad of what how bad was it what they
actually can i ask you a question yeah
okay here's a question for you all right
so how much of it is self-dep how much
of it is self-inflicted how much of it
is just fans being fans i mean i've been
to games where you're hearing people
calling out fans non-stop in the ugliest
ways right so one
how often do you hear a story like this
about steph curry you don't
how often do you hear stories like this
about mike trout you don't he's he's the
best player in mlb how many times your
stories like this about i don't know
pick the name of whatever how many times
you heard the story like this about
ronaldo how many times have you stored a
story like this about
pick any of these stores sure okay so
then here's what the next thing i say to
you is in the last 40 how are you 40 uh
40 40 years old okay about to be 41 on
february 4th which
is like 41-ish but 40 right now so how
many times in the last 30 years of
watching basketball
you've been watching basketball for how
long 30 years my whole life
last 30 years who have been the face of
the league last 30 years is it jordan
kobe and shaq and maybe
you had uh since the 80s you had bird
and magic for sure then jordan took over
then you had kobe shack okay allen
iverson was a facebook league real quick
they didn't want him to be the face of
the league but he was yeah he didn't
want to practice that was a problem so
we're talking about practice yeah so
we're good so uh and then you had some
dirk for a hot minute you had some you
know the heat over the face
freaking dirk being the face of the
league holy [ __ ]
man
they'll treat us they're facing the
league i come back here so here's the
question i wouldn't vote for trump
which face of the league have you ever
seen go up to reference to take the two
take these two guys out okay well let's
just get right in the comments what's
been said let's just say what the
comment was which who said that that was
said well listen okay at some point
you're just gonna have to believe
what do you think okay even if
let me just get this off my chest yeah
allegedly the couple and then it was the
girl that gave the little pouty face
she said i hope your son bronnie james
dies in a car accident
good luck shooting your free throws
buddy so what okay but at some point you
as a father you as a father of two kids
at some point you suck [ __ ] you doesn't
just rolls off your back you you now you
want my kid to die in a car accident
yeah something he's heard it so many
times adam and and okay
hear me out at some point though
at some point people have to learn dude
like some of the like the comments that
people make online and they just go
their little keyboard warriors and they
just go off to regular you know normal
work and they just
blaspheme whoever they want at some
point you have to pay a price for
talking stones may break my bones but
he's worth a billion dollars so the
freaking so he can't have feelings no
he's not he's got him but the thing is
he's a robot he's a robot poor lebron i
hope he recovers the thing about him is
now everybody in the world knows he's
listening to what's being said right he
just made it a thousand percent worse on
himself that every chirp that he's
always heard now people know he's
hearing him he's listening to him it's
the worst thing i got news for you buddy
people got ears and if i say hey kurt
you're an absolute piece of [ __ ] you're
going to be like bro right here in front
of you like what are you doing on an
infant saying like we have 11 years
on an infinitesimally smaller scale i
played minor league baseball ten
thousand people no no this is definitely
you lebron you and the minor leaguers
they hear everything they're saying you
hear everything they're saying toshi
nakamoto is jesus and you and played in
front of fans dude same exact thing i
get it you you hurt when you were
sitting on the bench at community
college football you heard what these
people were saying about you bro you but
you have to and i said these two right
here
i got something in two minutes so make
your point where the point is this one
you either let it go completely or to
your lebron james and you have something
funny to say where it's like he won't
get an accident because i can afford
drivers like or something like that you
you think that people didn't say this
crap to kobe you think they didn't say
spike lee and reggie miller for people
that are younger and don't know what
it's like to talk [ __ ] look at what
reggie miller did with spike lee with
the new york knicks in the playoffs all
these years spike lee was saying
everything you possibly could reggie
would hit the three and go right up to
him and say that one's for you [ __ ] and
that's how you play it and that's fine i
played back you know i played football
but you know what it was the referee
all the [ __ ] you want these people okay
the most horrifying thing so here's my
question for you
is there anything that anybody could say
that is grounds for dismissal to be
kicked out or anything they could say is
fair player is there anything that
somebody could say to say stones bro
your ability
if they did that you would hope that
somebody else would take care of it but
if they don't who cares it's a word as
soon you're as soon as they don't touch
you as soon as they as soon as they
touch you it's on but words lebron james
needs to be protected from words now
words it just makes them look soft i'm
not a big basketball fan but i saw that
it was like ooh like this it's just lame
it was not a good look it's just not i'm
not saying that he should have done it
but i'm saying at a certain point it's
crossing the line it shows your working
father and it's going to invite more you
get you get a lot of [ __ ] talking to you
you know probably more than a zodo doll
could they could they make something bad
let's hear it let's hear it from a
father
you get a lot of [ __ ] comments stupid
[ __ ] online everyone's tough behind
twitter everyone's tough on youtube
they're the toughest people in the world
youtube commenters but at some point
if someone says something about senna
at some point you're like hold up what
like as a father how do you respond to
this okay so who's so basic anyone
anyone's fan that's not how life works
that's how life works how would you
interpret if you say it
this is done we have a problem because
you are in the circle of course i have a
problem with you you're not gonna like
it if you say anything like that to me
if you say it if a guy off the street
says it what do you want me to do
if a guy off the street says i had a
couple choices i can whoop his ass
i can get him to make a few calls and
make that guy's life a living sammy okay
i can do all of that yeah of course and
if i do that and i go to jail then my
kid's not gonna see me for two months so
he caused me to lose two months with my
daughter's life i don't know if it's
worth it but if somebody on the inside
says it it is what it you know we can
have a problem now let me continue
we have something called twitter i don't
know if you've been to that website
there's a guy that was running jack
dorsey
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so this twitter
website you know what things they've
said to obama about trump
about anybody and ever you ever gone
read the comments it is brutal right
tough job people in the world
take it if he can't take it i mean buddy
i think listen is that the worst comment
ever made in the history of basketball
no how many times you think people
probably called somebody certain awards
in the 80s 90s and michael still went
out there and won the game so in boston
too yeah i don't know all i'm saying to
you is all i'm saying to you is this
sets the precedence that censorship is
now going into games and sports period
you got to sit there and be like
right you know what i would like i would
like i don't like that i would like the
people that made the comment because i
think they did make this comment to have
a conversation when we invite them can
we can we say no can get a hold of them
no no let's invite them to the next
podcast sure can you do that and just
say how are we going to justify
saying a comment like this we'll do that
to make you feel uh good about it and
then we'll go from there anyway they
should be held accountable if they
didn't say that exactly totally i don't
think it's lebron james who should be
the guy that's like guys i feel you on
that but at some point the [ __ ] talker
by the way they gotta be this this is
they gotta be this is where i come from
this is where i come from say i'm in a
place okay
guy and a girl are fighting guy slaps
her in the face in the face guy hits a
girl guy hits a girl on her face
what i'm saying to you is i'm gonna do
something about it okay so if somebody
around them is sitting there guys say
something like that i'm gonna be like
what is the freaking matter with you
like in the stand i'd be sitting next to
you saying what does that matter with
you i agree are you freaking stupid i
would call your ass 100 percent we would
have a problem so this is what man on
facebook yeah let the people handle it
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]